Islam does, in its core texts, actually
condemn Christian teaching.
Okay? And so, for example, and we're
going to we're going to look at this in
greater detail, uh what does it condemn
specifically? Actually, the most
important aspects of Christianity. You
hear a lot of people who want you to
believe and and tell you, "Oh, well,
there's a lot of commonalities
commonalities between Muslims and
Christians." And a lot of it does, you
know, ostensibly seem pretty impressive.
For example, um Muslims believe in the
Quran indicates and so does the Hadith
that Jesus was born of a virgin.
And that he was sinless. That he
performed miracles. And that he will
also be present at the end days. Pretty
good stuff. You'd think you can build a
bridge on that, right? Okay. The
problem, however, is if you're a real
Christian, or at least know what
Christianity is about, those aspects of
Christ's
existence are actually all very
secondary. What does matter is what
recently passed, if you're Catholic or
Protestant, and what's coming up, if
you're Orthodox, which is Easter,
Resurrection Sunday. That, I'll have you
know, Islam vehemently opposes,
forcefully. If you look at the Quran, it
makes unequivocally clear, the Quran,
not just the Hadith, okay, that Jesus
wasn't even crucified. And he certainly
as such, that means he didn't die. And
therefore, obviously, there's no room
for any resurrections. And therefore, he
is certainly not the son of God. Well,
guess what? That right there is the most
core important teaching of Christianity,
all right? Which is what's captured by
Easter Sunday, Resurrection Sunday. So,
think about that. This is a so-called
religion which, in its core teachings,
goes out of its way
>> [snorts]
>> to condemn the core teachings of
Christianity. Could it be that there's a
diabolical element behind it?
Okay? Because we're going to see, due to
that, Islam has reeked great havoc
amongst Christians from the past until,
if not even more so, in the present,
okay? Now, I've said this many times.
I've given you the historical background
of what I'm talking about, but again,
obviously, it's important, so let me
recap real quick. In the 7th century,
when Islam blew out of Arabia, after
Muhammad's death in 632, in 732, one
century, it had conquered a humongous,
massive chunk, at least 2/3 of the
Christian world. And it went on to
conquer 3/4 of the Christian world later
on, uh with the Ottomans who took over
so much of Eastern Europe, the Balkans,
and the Tatars, who were also Muslim.
So, long and short of it is about 75% of
the Christian world was swallowed up by
Islam. And guess what? It was very
violent, a very savage, a very bloody,
full of all sorts of atrocities. Okay?
The countries we all assume were Muslim
or Eastern or Oriental or whatever term
anyone wants to use, they actually were
the most Christian nations at the time
of the rise of Islam. And this would be
the Middle East, which, surprise
surprise, of course it would be the most
Christian. That's where Christianity
arose, right? So, that makes sense.
Basically, the entire Middle East, all
those countries today, Syria, Lebanon,
Jordan, Iraq, Israel, Palestinian
territories, I'm giving you the their
modern terms, the whole Middle East, of
course. Egypt, Libya, Tunisia, Algeria,
Morocco. All these countries which today
are just nonchalantly referred to as the
Islamic world, as if they always were,
were actually more Christian than
Europe, which went on to become very
Christian. And actually, it's
interesting, that's why it's ironic,
because Europe today, which is so
secular, having been uh completely
slaughtered by Satan's spiritual sword,
which we're going to get into, it
actually used to be such a fierce
Christian warrior as an entity because
of all these conquests. It was all that
was left over. It was the final bastion
of Christendom. And it had to just fight
for its life against the behemoth known
as Islam, which, just as mentioned,
despises the gospel message, which is
captured in Easter. Okay? And we can go
on and on. I've talked about, okay,
after this massive conquest of formerly
Christian lands, this is what, of
course, what provoked the Crusades,
which everyone is so obsessed with
demonizing as if they just happened out
of the blue and had no actual context.
No, right before the first Crusade,
Muslims were doing what they had always
been doing, but even more so, burning
thousands of churches throughout Asia
Minor, slaughtering Christians,
Armenians, Syrians, Greeks, and killing
and raping European pilgrims, and doing
all sorts of other atrocities. You can
check out chapter, I think, five of
Sword and Scimitar or chapter one of
Defenders of the West, if you have them,
if you want actual quotes with citations
of how bad it was. Okay? So, that's what
was happening right before the first
Crusade, which we all have to say, "Oh,
but bad things happened."
But we don't hear about what the Muslims
were doing right before that. And this,
of course, continues on and on. We can
talk about all the mass slavery that the
Muslims engaged in of Europeans, meaning
of Christians, because to be a European
then meant your identity wasn't white or
European, it was, "I'm a Christian."
That's why they were preyed upon
specifically. And so, you had all that
going on. And I you I've given you these
stats before. In the 16th century, 1.25
million white European Christian slaves
just in Barbary, meaning North Africa,
and even more in the Ottoman territories
and in the in the in the Tatar Mongol
Khanate, especially the Crimean uh
Khanate and the Golden Horde preceding
it. Okay, you're talking about many
millions of Christians. And we don't
Here's the thing, we don't actually know
the the true number. You know why?
Because whereas Western people actually
kept records of slaves, that's why we
can talk with some accuracy, Muslims
didn't. Uh it didn't matter. They're
just slaves. We're not going to keep
records. Just haul them in, tie them up,
chain them, use them, abuse them, kill
them. These are like animals. Who's
going to keep records? So, that's of
course one of the reasons. Anyway, this
sort of thing goes on um until uh you
know, like I said, America's first war
as a nation is with Muslims talking and
acting just like jihadists and ISIS.
Okay? So, that's what Islam does once it
enters the scene. It takes over what
Rome had been doing, which is physically
persecuting with the sword Christians.
Okay? Hear now the words of James or
Jacques of Vitry. Okay? Uh this was the
uh Bishop of Acre or Acre or however you
want to pronounce it, which was in the
Holy Land. And writing around uh 1220,
which is now nearly a millennium, 1,000
years after Eusebius' times, about how
Rome physically attacked Christians
within wonders of wonders, Constantine
ended the suffering, but then here we
got the subversive false Christians
entering in and subverting. Here's what
he writes in 1220, James of Vitry, um
Bishop of Acre. First, he describes
Christianity as, quote, "besieged on all
sides by enemies." These enemies were,
as usual, on the one hand, physical,
corporeal, and obvious, Muslims.
And on the other, spiritual
and subversive, false
Christians.
And people claiming to be working on
behalf and helping Christianity. Okay?
Here are his words, quote, "Saracens and
pagans undermine the peace of
Christendom. Tyrants and evil Christians
attack the liberty of the church, and
false brethren undermine love." So, for
James and most Christians of the time,
in that context, when you're being
attacked, like he said, on all sides,
both physically and spiritually, the
only answer was to fight fire with fire
by taking up the two swords of Christ.
So, here is one perfect example of an
early Christian authority, a bishop,
talking about the two swords of Christ
the way I described it to you. He
continues, quote, "Against the violence
of the pagans and Saracens, the church
uses the physical sword." Hence, the
Crusades.
"Against tyrants and false brothers, it
uses a spiritual sword, which it also
uses against heretics and schismatics.
Since the church has two swords, which
the Lord has said is enough,
one is to be exercised in a spiritual
sense
>> [snorts]
>> by the prelates, the other by princes
and military Christians."
And by the way, the the biblical verse
about, you know, the two swords are
enough, that's Luke 22:38, for the
record. So, there it is. Now, as for
told by that verse in Ecclesiastes,
nothing has since changed. Okay?
If the same double-pronged attack
described by Eusebius in the 4th century
was still on display nine centuries
later when James of Vitry of Acre was
writing, today, in the 21st century, a
full 18 centuries after James, it's
worse than ever.
And the reason you don't know that is
because the subversive sword has worked
so well.
That's exactly how powerful that
subversive sword has been. You sense
something is wrong, but you don't really
understand what it is.
So,
the long and short of it, of course, is
that Satan's two swords, which I
described to you, run red with Christian
blood both physically and spiritually
right now, at this very moment, than at
any other time in history. More than
during the Roman persecutions,
quantitatively, more than during the
high rise or the high times of the
Islamic jihads on Europe. And I'm going
to give you the proof. So, what's the
difference as I just indicated? The
primary difference is that today's
Christians, particularly those in the
West, are utterly clueless about this.
That the physical sword of violence is
wreaking havoc more so than ever. And
the fact that they're clueless is itself
proof and highlights the great degree to
which Western Christians have succumbed
to Satan's other sword, the spiritual
sword. Okay? Bring back
the fire.
Bring back
the flame.
the fire
and the
>> [music]
>> righteousness.